The trick to this dynamic optimization, is recognizing what
the state of the protocol is at any point of
time, and how the protocol has to react to
an input event. Whether the event is coming from the
top, or from the bottom, how the protocol has
to react to that event is the trick, and this
is what is called the common case predicate. CCP
for short. For example, if we receive a packet and
the state of the protocol says that if a
particular sequence number is received, then we are ready
to deliver the packet to the application. If that
is the state of the protocol, that is what
is called a Common Case Predicate. These Common Case
Predicates are predicates that can be derived From the
state of the protocol, by looking at the conditional
statement. So, from the conditional statements in the microprotocol
that have been implemented and available to you. We
can actually synthesize these common case predicates. And once these
common case predicates have been synthesized, then we can say,
well, if the common case predicate is satisfied, then you
don't have to go through all the craft indicated by
the multiple layers of the micro protocols assembled on top
of one another. But instead, we can do a much
simpler processing and that's what is called a bypass code.
So, in the dynamic optimization, once these
common case predicates have been identified by
looking at the conditional statements in the
micro protocol, dynamic optimization framework, generates these bypass
code and inserts it into this framework.
So I'm going to complicate this picture a little
bit now, so what we have is A Common Case predicate. For instance it says,
is the sequence number in the packet what I
am expecting it to be. Is this the particular sequence
number? And if that is the sequence number I am
looking for, then I can execute this bypass code and
completely eliminate all these multiple layers of protocol and
go directly to the upper layer perhaps all the way
up to the application. On the other hand, if it
is not the common case predicate that is being satisfied,
then, you have to do the normal processing, of giving
the packet to this micro protocol and it does its
own thing. And you can see that this kind of
framework can be applied to every layer. So you can
take, this is a single layer, and find out what
the common case predicate for this micro-protocol, and use that
common case predicate to signify whether we want to use the
bypass code, or whether we want to go to the micro-protocol.
And we can collapse multiple layers like this. And
derive a common case predicate that collapses all of
these layers into a single predicate, and if it
is satisfied, then it can eliminate processing the packet to
all of these layers, and simply go through the
bypass code to get to the upper layers. That's
the beauty of the dynamic optimization, and it's completely
automated. And it comes from the power of the theorem
proving framework of Nuprl. And the optimization
theorem that is in the Nuprl framework proves
the equivalence of the bypass code, to
the layers of protocol that it is replacing.
That's the beauty of the Nuprl framework,
that in the theoretical world of the theorem
proving framework, we can actually prove through
optimization theorems. That this bypass code does exactly
the same job as all of these multiple layers of micro protocols that were to
process this message. So once we have done
this dynamic optimization, and collapsing the layers, generating
the bypass code, starting of course with
the common case predicate derived from the micro
protocols, then we are ready, to convert the
optimized new Pearl called back to OCaml. And
again, I mentioned that there is a tool,
that, that's available. Straight forward tool that converts
the new Pearl code to the OCaml code, and the final OCaml code that we generate
through this conversion process is the optimized version of the original Ocaml
code and, the theorem proving framework can assert that the original
unoptimized ocaml code is equivalent. To the new optimized Ocaml
call because of the power of the
theorem proving framework. This is where we've sort
of put together theory and practice to get the best of both worlds. A word of
caution, however. There's a difference between optimization and verification.
All that the NuPrl framework is doing is optimization, not verifying whether the
Ocaml code is adhering to behavioral spec of ioatometer.
That's not what is being done. What we're doing here, is saying that. We've
taken unoptimized Ocamel code and produce an
optimized Ocamel code. And through the theoretical
framework, we can assert that the two
are functionally equivalent. So this exercise has
shown the path to synthesizing complex system
software, starting from specification, to implementation to
optimization, putting theory and practice together.